- You know you have this dream,
and sometimes you need to
let loose of that dream
because it's not going to work out,
but I always give the
advice that, you know,
you should really try to stick it out
as long as possible because some things,
good things tend to take a long time.
(inspiring music)
My name is Philipp Man,
I am one of the founders of Chronext,
the full service platform
for luxury watches.
Chronext is a online
marketplace for luxury watches,
so we have over 600 retailers worldwide
who buy sell and service
their watches for us,
and we take of their
shipment, the logistics,
the authentication,
payment, the whole presale
and after sale service.
So when you buy from us,
it feels like buying
at a boutique offline,
but you have all the benefits
of an online marketplace.
My co-founder and I,
we both started the
business in our kitchen
in London, Maida Vale,
and we were both watch geeks, essentially,
and we understood that there's actually,
there's no platform for
buying luxury watches online
or selling them in a safe way.
We thought, okay, luxury watches,
it's a passion product,
it's not a big market,
but we realized, actually, you know,
it's a 90,000,000,000 annual industry,
and there's no one doing it,
so let's just try it.
So we bootstrapped the business
for one and a half years,
and the turning point
really came after we raised
out first round of
financing because it allowed
us to invest into, really, marketing
and kind of the technology
behind it to get to know
the customer and give a better experience
to the customer,
and after three and a half years now,
we are probably one of
the largest resellers
in the world for luxury watches.
I think the motivation
for me personally is,
you are confronted with issues,
you have no idea how to solve them,
it's a completely new
kind of playing field,
you've never done this before.
And you work at it,
and you keep trying and
trying and trying and trying,
and you still haven't found a solution,
and then suddenly there's just a spark,
and you know, it solves a
complex problem for you.
And, the gratification of
being able to solve something
that a hundred other people in the company
may not have been doing, or,
they've been waiting for you to do it,
is, is quite big, because
it shows that, you know,
when you really dedicate all your focus
and your time to something,
it can pay off a lot.
Luxury watches may seem very trivial,
but actually it's something
what people save for,
a long time, to really buy this item.
It's not something that
you just buy like this,
you know, it's something
to mark an anniversary,
to mark a big success in your life,
so people really take
a lot of time to think
what they're going to buy,
where they're going to buy it.
So every time a customer
buys from us is a success.
(inspiring music)